Democrats are blasting President Biden
for his quote shockingly inhumane border
proposal which will make migrants
ineligible to claim asylum in the U.S if
they pass through other countries
without seeking Refuge there first the
administration says the measure which is
very similar to a trump-era rule would
be temporary to help with the strain at
the border when title 42 goes away Tom
Homan is a former acting ice director
and a Fox News contributor and Tom you
know the Border issues very well you
have said that this proposal is long
overdue and I'm I'm sure have a lot more
to say about it but my question to you
is you know Democrats are saying it's
inhumane and that it shouldn't have
happened
but the border patrol says folks are
still going to be able to Acclaim Asylum
clear this up for us
well look I I do think when someone
claims Asylum if they're escaping let's
say they're claiming Asylum from
Honduras because they they fear they
have a fear of persecution from their
home government that's what Asylum is so
if they get to Mexico have they not
escaped that fear of persecution from
the home government of course they
should they should claim Asylum the
first free country they come to I
believe in that but this Administration
look it's it's smoking mirrors again
they're going to establish his rules but
there's so many exceptions to the rule
that the exception is going to swallow
the rule they just got to come to the
board to say well I fear for my life and
how do we just prove that they fear for
their life so there's going to be so
many exceptions to this rule it's not
going to matter what really concerns
about this Administration why don't they
do something that's already been proven
effective and the federal courts already
said it's legal they remain a Mexico
program you don't have to worry about
title 42 you don't have to worry about
this the the fake policies you're coming
up with title 42 is it worked it was a
game changer the highest courts in lands
that was legal people still claim Asylum
but they went in Mexico but this
Administration won't do it they keep
coming up these policies that they will
lose in court and they know they will
lose in court and here's their game when
they lose in court they can say well we
were solving the board of Crisis numbers
going down the Republican states came in
and sued us now the numbers going back
up this is the game they're playing the
policies they're creating are unlawful
they won't work but they're ignoring the
policies that did work under the Trump
Administration
what do you mean that the policies that
they're creating are unlawful and don't
work
if they're being accused for instance
having the same policies as as a trump
Administration that you're saying did
work explain that for me what you mean
there
good I'm not sure policy so the Trump is
the Trump Administration they had to
remain in Mexico program we even claim
Assam but your own way in Mexico but for
instance the parole policy this thing
will parole 30 000 people in that's
illegal Pro policy clearly states the
statute clearly says that it has to be a
case-by-case analysis based on the
circumstances and the facts of each case
that must result in a significant public
benefit for the country
they're not doing that they're saying 30
000 a month are coming in where's the
case-by-case analysis they will lose
this in court that's why 20 states are
suing them this latest policy when they
created the rule they made all these
exceptions to the rule that that might
have swallowing the rule so the Trump
Administration did it differently they
established a program where you can
still claim Asylum but you're going
outside the country this Administration
is is creating a a a a a a policy where
we're going to make illegal immigration
legal and bring us to the port of
entries it's not going to work they're
going to lose I want to ask how do you
respond to Senate Democrats who are
saying this call for it number one we're
deeply disappointed that the
Administration has chosen to move
forward with this publishing this
proposal rule which only perpetuates the
harmful myth that Asylum Seekers are a
threat to this nation uh immigration
Advocates Democrats alike have said you
know our
guiding principle is that if you set
foot on American soil you have the right
to claim Asylum here and they're upset
about this policy what's your your
response to that
first of all they want completely open
borders they don't want any rules of who
comes in the country and I would say
this is Democrats look at the data the
Immigration Court data says this 9 out
of 10 people who claim Asylum at our
border never get relief from the U.S
courts because either don't show up they
don't qualify nine out of ten that means
millions of these Asylum Seekers are
going to be ordered removed they also
know this Homeland Security life cycle
report says if they're not detained only
six percent will leave so the millions
that will lose your case are never
leaving because they'll go in the wind
and wait for the next Amy steamer come
across so the Democrats want to take a
pick a side in this issue look at the
facts the fact says nine out of 10
commit Asylum fraud they don't qualify
they and they're clogging up the system
for thousands of people around the world
that really are escaping fear and
persecution in these United States
assistance the debt is clearly shows
it's a massive Asylum fraud and they
need to deal with that and they need to
secure the Border securing the Border
saves lives securing the Border ensures
that only those with with real Asylum
claims will get processed such as remain
in Mexico you still get heard your case
will get heard you get schedules for
court but you're not being released
United States to remain here for decades
after you get order removed by a court
Tom Holland appreciate you always being
with us no one knows the Border quite as
well as you do so thank you so much for
your time sir